ich habe heute eine auszubildende dabei
dass die vertriebswege
sie haben immer viel zu sehen sein danke
papa wartet schon sehnlichst
na gut geschlafen sieht man noch ja ich
habe heute die vertreter dabei ist die
neue auszubildende in genf die schweizer
patrick herrmann
wir würden uns kalt war vorbereiten will
die zu ihm kommen und uns um sie kümmern
ja dann fangen wir direkt mal damit an
die beine zu waschen
okay okay so dass die patientenakte hier
vorne ist immer der standort dann kann
es einfach die stammdaten sehen dann hat
die diagnosen die ja für uns relevant
sind zum beispiel diabetes mellitus wird
insulinpflichtige ist ja das müssen wir
beachten nachher die leistung der nato
dann kannst du sehen was wir noch machen
im vierzehnten besucher kleinen fleck
sein hut das machen wir die beine wird
etwas besonderes war genau das so haben
das sehen wir sagen die hände dann gehen
wir das einmal zusammen durch die
patrizia wird jetzt einmal die beine
waschen ja ich werde ein bisschen drauf
gucken und schauen ob alles so weit okay
ist und ob wir etwas verbessern können
ja und haben doch mächtigen sie sei eben
die wasser haaren bitte möchte sie seife
im wasser haben ja das steht schon alles
da vorne bereit beim guten schuss da
muss ich natürlich aus
wichtig ist den schritt immer den
patienten zu erklären ich genau was du
eigentlich tust dass ihr das rechte bein
anheben damit er sich erschreckt und
genau ich habe jetzt erst mal hier recht
den wein und ich fange mit waschen
genau wie steht diesmal gegen die haar
richtung garten morgens weil wir damit
den patienten aktivieren ja abends
würden wir zum beispiel mit der
hagelsturm waschen
ja wir würden als nächstes die
blutzuckermessung machen um zu gucken
wie der blutzucker ist und entsprechend
seien insulin spritzen damit er dann
frühstücken kann herum macht ich würde
gerne einmal den blutzucker bei ihnen
messen ja da dürfen sie mir einmal eine
hand zur verfügung stellen
dann nehmen wir uns den blutzucker und
du würdest hier einmal quasi ziehen dass
es ein rastet dass sie hier den punkt
wurde braucht rücken könnte und springt
einer nadel raus wenn du den ersten
tropfen weg und dann hat sie hier das
gerät wurde das wird auf trägst du
siehst hier die markierung hier kommt es
auf den blutdruck und dann berechnet das
gerät hier quasi den blutzuckergehalt
aus damals 160
das ist völlig in ordnung
dementsprechend haben wir 160 ist der
blutzucker das ist in ordnung
jaja da fangen sich offenbar gleich mal
mit soliden gefühl geben ja gut